les français traversent actuellement des
heures difficiles et la situation est
grave la france le pays que nous aimons
et frappé simultanément par plusieurs
crises sanitaires économiques et
sociales mais aussi par le totalitarisme
islamiste à nouveau au nom de mon groupe
je voudrais monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
m'associer à la fois hommage mais
surtout salué la mémoire des victimes de
toutes les victimes
ces victimes monsieur le premier
ministre elle vous oblige je vous ai
posé cette semaine une question
d'actualité pour vous dire que nous
étions en train de perdre du terrain
dans ce grand combat contre l'islamisme
elle vous oblige à sortir des solutions
toutes faites des demi mesures
on y parviendra pas avec des
demi-mesures j'en suis persuadé je pense
qu'il faut un combat global mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi sortir du cadre
si vous restez dans le cadre vous
continuerez à faire des déclarations
nous continuerons à faire des hommages
et les crimes se poursuivront en france
et ailleurs
cette situation la gravité de cette
situation et chers collègues nous oblige
à la fois à la responsabilité et à la
hauteur et je pense qu'il n'est pas
inutile de vous rappeler monsieur le
premier ministre notre état d'esprit
la ligne que nous nous sommes donnés
depuis le début des attentats depuis le
début de cette crise responsabilités et
exigence responsabilité nous avons été
au rendez vous nous avons voté tous les
textes que vous nous avez proposé tous à
chaque fois la responsabilité est la
nôtre de vous donner les moyens de
gouverner pour protéger les français
mais en phase
cette responsabilité il y a une exigence
l'exigence de la vérité l'exigence que
nous devons d'un point de vue
démocratique à nos concitoyens à nos
compatriotes les français les français
qui eux mêmes s'interrogent et nous nous
devons de relayer ces interrogations
leurs interrogations parce qu'elles sont
légitimes et nous sommes là pour cela
nous l'avons été mandatée vous vous êtes
exprimé à plusieurs reprises sur l'unité
nationale
très bien mais l'unité nationale ça ne
peut pas être le prétexte pour imposer
le silence dans l'europe dans les rangs
ça ne peut pas être le prétexte pour
museler l'opposition nationale vous
aviez monsieur le premier ministre
une bonne occasion une occasion de
sceller cette union nationale ce soir
nous allons examiner un texte il va vous
donner les moyens de réaliser ce que
vous nous avez annoncé nous allons voter
sans doute après l'avoir amendé mais
vous avez maintenu dans les
circonstances que nous connaissons un
vote au titre de l'article 5 en tirez
vous auriez pu le reporter sort était
évidemment la preuve que vous étiez
attachés à cette unité nationale vous ne
l'avez pas fait alors que c'est un vote
pour eux rien il n'est qu'indicatif 1
de confiance sans doute que vous nous
donnerons pas un vote pourra rien un
vote donc inutile mais dans ces
circonstances
était-il vraiment nécessaire de le
confirmer
je pense que la responsabilité qui est
la nôtre est de vous donner les moyens
que vous souhaiter pour enrayer
l'épidémie et nous le ferons
votre responsabilité monsieur le premier
ministre et de nous écouter et de rendre
des comptes pour le sénat mais aussi
pour tous les français on a souvent
parlé de guerre guerre contre les russes
guerre contre le totalitarisme islamiste
et je me souviens cette métaphore
qu'avait utilisé le président de
république
au printemps dernier une métaphore suivi
d'une anna fort
la répétition à six reprises du terme
sommes en guerre
nous sommes en guerre nous sommes en
guerre mais n'est pas clemenceau qui
veut que reste-t-il que reste-t-il sept
mois après de cette déclaration de
guerre
la france sur le pied de guerre non la
france au pied du mur hier le président
de république nous a annoncé les mesures
de confinement
je n'ai rien trouvé dans le discours
monsieur le premier ministre qui
distingue le contenu de ce discours de
ce que nous avons attendu des décisions
c'était donc bien que vous vouliez ce
débat vous vouliez ce vote mais les jeux
sont faits tout est décidé mes chers
collègues
c'est un théâtre d'ombrés ce débat est
ce vote à l'évidence
[Applaudissements]
et bien ce débat était organisé sept
mois après que reste-t-il
que reste-t-il de ces déclarations vous
nous avez indiqué à plusieurs reprises
que c'est vrai cette seconde vague est
la même pour tout le monde pour tous les
pays d'europe et nous sommes nous sommes
confrontés aux mêmes difficultés au même
virus mais nous n'avons pas les mêmes
résultats mes chers collègues dans
plusieurs outils qui compare les pays
les uns contre les autres
la france n'est pas en bon rang pour la
mortalité cinquième rang pour la
mortalité mes chers collègues
est-ce qu'on peut s'en satisfaire est ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est partout pareil
et qu'on fait comme les autres noms ont
fait plus mal que les autres ont fait à
la fois plus mal que les autres mais on
a le niveau de dépenses de santé aux
premiers rangs par rapport aux autres
c'est là qu'est le problème qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pour qu'on en arrive là
je sais qu'il faut être humble bien sûr
mais la vérité on la doit aussi aux
français
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est pour
nous et incompréhensible si je reprends
les déclarations du ministre de la santé
n'est pas là une déclaration par exemple
dans un journal du dimanche du 28 mars
dernier l'anticipation a été absolu
depuis le premier jour c'était écrit
parce qu'il l'avait déclaré comment
expliquer ses mauvaises performances
si le ministre de la santé était aussi
définitif aussi péremptoire comme il est
toujours bien sûr au fil de nos
questions d'actualité chaque mercredi
les collègues en savent quelque chose
alain milon en sait quelque chose
simplement que s'est il passé
les deux raisons qui aboutit ce résultat
que nous connaissons
c'est à la fois l'imprévision que notre
commission d' enquête a d'ailleurs
commencé à révéler comme celle de nos
collègues députés l'imprévision et
l'impréparation
l'imprévision c'est celle qui a prévalu
pendant le confinement pas de masse pas
de gel pas de blues mais malheureusement
pas de cap pas de stratégie nous avons
été ici au sénat dès le mois de mars
indiqué qu'une mise sous cloche était
une stratégie uniquement défensive mais
qu'elle aurait dû s'accompagner de la
seule stratégie qui permettent de briser
les reins de l'épidémie testez tracé
isolé et cela n'a pas été fait et une
fois la cloche retirer le virus est
reparti l'impréparation ensuite c'était
le déconfinement et l'été parce que vous
n'avez pas su profiter du répit que le
virus
vous avez donné et on ne peut pas dire
qu'on ne savait pas parce que dès le
mois de juillet dès le mois de juillet
le conseil scientifique c'est pas nous
qui avons nommé les membres du conseil
scientifique qui avons choisi son
président dès le mois de juillet le
conseil scientifique nous avertissait
d'une seconde vague possible et dès la
rentrée le 9 septembre
très exactement le président du conseil
scientifique toujours lui avait déclaré
je cite ces mots très exactement le
gouvernement devra prendre des décisions
difficiles sous huit à dix jours
vous aviez fait à l'époque quelques
jours après monsieur le premier ministre
une conférence de presse où vous aviez
annoncé que vous transformiez la 14ème
en petite semaine donc nous n'avons pas
profité de ce moment de répit estival
pour pouvoir nous préparer en
particulier pour pouvoir augmenter le
nombre de lits de réanimation nous en
sommes toujours d'ailleurs aux mêmes
chiffres
il comprit contre les allégations en
commission d' enquête du ministre de la
santé et ceux qui étaient mises en échec
à ce moment là c'est la fameuse de
stratégie moi j'avais été heureux
d'ailleurs d'entendre d'autres
prédécesseur ici même dans son discours
de déconfinement dire voilà maintenant
on va tester des pistes et on va tracer
et on va isoler mais cette stratégie a
été battu en brèche le dépistage
on a fait du chiffre jusqu'à un million
deux par jour
j'ai entendu certains s'en gargariser
mais ça sert à quoi de faire des tests
de les généraliser si les résultats
arrivent trop tard
et si ceux qui doivent être testés ne le
sont pas en réalité ça ne sert à rien
pourquoi est ce que le ministère du
travail
à l'époque avait t-il interdit aux
entreprises est la médecine du travail
de participer au dépistage pourquoi
pourquoi les laboratoires publics n'ont
pas été suffisamment associés échec de
cette première stratégie de dépistage et
cet échec sur le traçage je ne parle pas
de stop loving simplement on a envoyé
les fameuses brigades en vacances
pendant l'été
et oui en juillet et en août faut
prendre de vacances sauf que c'est là
que se sont multipliées les clusters et
que le virus a circulé un rythme de plus
en plus important de plus en plus
accéléré on traçait aux mortiers par cas
positifs cinq cas on a tracé plus il ya
quelques semaines que 2k échec sur le
traçage et échec sur l'isolation sur l'
isolement
l' isolement dans mon propre département
ces trois personnes depuis le mois de
mai c'est un sdf et de travailleurs
étrangers
on n'a pas vraiment isolé alors qu'il y
avait des hôtels qui pouvait être
réquisitionnés qu'ils pourraient être
mobilisés
voilà où nous en sommes et les
frontières
pourquoi est ce que au mois d'août
le conseil scientifique toujours lui
vous enjoins d'isoler absolument les
passagers qui venait des zones rouges et
que rien n'est fait pourquoi si ce n'est
cette idée que les frontières doivent
toujours et je l ai entendu encore hier
soir restait ouverte
en tout cas les frontières
intra-européennes jeu le premier
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est cette accumulation des chèques
ce sont ces manquements à l'anticipation
je sais que ça n'était pas facile mais
ce sont des manquements à l'anticipation
qui vous conduisent aujourd'hui art
confiné ce sont les français qui vont en
payer le prix fort en termes de liberté
de libertés publiques bien sûr mais
aussi
en terme de souffrance économique et
social n'en doutons pas parce que leur
confinement c'est aussi un cortège de
souffrances sociales
je voudrais simplement dire que il a été
question de l'activité connu je ne doute
pas et si elle n'est pas sûre se feront
d'ailleurs que nous avons beaucoup de
reproches à vous faire parce que je
pense que le gouvernement a plutôt bien
accompagner l'économie et à chaque fois
nous avions voté d'ailleurs les projets
de finances rectificatif mais de grâce
de grâce ne massacre et pas les
commerces de proximité à quoi cela
sert-il
à quoi cela sert-il de fermer la
librairie de la rue celui qui vend des
chaussures alors que les français iront
acheter dans les grandes surfaces
alors je vous demande vous le président
rémy sur le premier liste vous le
précise ray vous le précise ray vous le
précise vrai mais c'est une évidence
sentent sans doute
trouvez vous que ces critiques sont
injustes là ce n'est pas moi qui la
première fois et désigner des ratés
cette prison dorée public le 13 avril
hier encore hier soir il a dit mais
avons-nous tout bien fait non d'évidence
de même souvent vous nous avez accuse
effectivement de ne pas proposer
m'attendais on a tous voter et on a voté
dans tous les textes des dizaines et des
dizaines d'amendements deux propositions
à chaque fois est ce que vous croyez que
ce top cow vide au sénat serait passé le
premier sans mon engagement personnel
qu'avait j'avais à gagner à l'époque
rien du tout simplement je pensais dans
la stratégie de traçage c'était une
affaire de cohérence et j'ai emmené mon
groupe et j'ai emmené mon groupe
justement pour ce vote c'était une
question de responsabilité
alors nous allons continuer nous allons
continuer à proposer
nous continuerons à proposer à proposer
pour que la france reprenne le contrôle
de l'épidémie a proposé pour que les
français reprennent le cours d'une vie
normale
ce que nous souhaiterions monsieur le
prémice messieurs mesdames messieurs les
ministres
c'est un plan d'anticipation enfin un
plan d'anticipation qui permettent à la
fois de soigner les malades
tous les malades et qui permettent aussi
de traquer la maladie soigner les
malades y compris les plus âgés faisons
en sorte dans cette phase là que comme
l'a révélé notamment la commission
d'enquêté de l'assemblée nationale que
les personnes âgées ne soit pas mis de
côté pour l'accès aux soins en
réanimation à l'hôpital
c'est très important mais on doit
pouvoir multiplier les lie
comme le disait un ami lyon hier
faciliter l'entente l'articulation entre
l'hôpital la clinique privée et publique
faire en sorte d'ouvrir des hôpitaux
éphémère c'est une idée du professeur
jules 20 je connais une très belle
entreprise vendéenne qui plus est qui
peut qui peut installer on n'a rien de
temps des modulaires accélérer les
formations comme l'ont fait les italiens
aujourd'hui vous savez que chez moi à la
bruffière un ehpad 63 cas sur 84 et le
personnel indisponibles le directeur le
maire ont fait appel justement à la
réserve sanitaire n'y a pas de réserve
sanitaire
il faut il faut bien sûr former la
réserve sanitaire
aujourd'hui dans cet ehpad ce sont les
conseillers municipaux et du ccas qui
vont donner un coup de main bénévolement
voilà ce qu'il faut faire multiplier les
lis parce que aujourd'hui l'action
publique et cap et par le nombre de lits
de réanimation et puis tract est
vraiment la maladie l'a aussi traqué la
et des pistes et des pistes est vraiment
massivement avec le test antigénique
deux mâts les tests salivaires dépister
la en mobilisant toutes les énergies
tous les acteurs de santé y compris la
médecine de travail fait en sorte de
casser aussi les rentes cette épidémie
par exemple là encore en traçant
vraiment en isolant réquisitionner des
hôtels iso
les gens en isolement qui souhaitent
accompagner avec des sms qu'on
industrialise les frontières qu'il faut
aussi faire mais nous avons des
propositions à vous faire monsieur le
premier vous ne pouvez pas dire que
l'opposition ne se contente que de
critiquer nous avons depuis le départ
fait ici des propositions au sénat
maintenant je voudrais terminer pour
vous dire qu'elle est finalement le sens
du vote que vous lui demandez ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas le sens du vote de vous
donner les moyens pour les mesures ce
sera le vote de ce soir
pour le tec sur l'urgence vous nous
demandez finalement une confiance
cette confiance nous ne pouvons pas vous
l'accordé nous ne pouvons pas signer un
chèque en blanc
les français ne font plus confiance je
pense que ce vote est inutile
ce vote est inutile je vous souhaite de
tout coeur et nous serons toujours
disponibles pour vous donner les moyens
de réussir
réussissez et je vous souhaite de
réussir monsieur le premier avec votre
gouvernement avec le président
république parce qu'il en va de l'avenir
de la france et surtout dans ces moments
si difficiles qui concentre tous les
dangers il en va de la destinée commune
du peuple de france
si la parole
[Applaudissements]
la parole est
la parole est au président claude
malhuret
[Musique]